c'est bizarre je crois comme ça c'est
comme s'il est en fait un ciel les kings
c'est vraiment comme du labour
aujourd'hui on a proposé un atelier
papier antemoro donc c'est un papier à
base de matières végétales
donc c'est les corses d'un arbre qui
vient de madagascar la voa est en fait
les enfants vont mixer vont préparer la
pâte et vont faire du papier
donc on peut faire des cartes postales
des cartes de voeux ou même du papier à
lettres avec le papier antemoro et
l'avantagé c'est que les enfants
touchent à la pâte et ils vont aussi
mettre de la matière végétale dessus
comme des petites fleurs et repartir
avec leur préparation
d'accord c'est plutôt amusant j'ai mûri
j'ai mis les pattes de dans l'eau après
j'ai en afrique ma main pour me plati
après j'ai tiré j'ai métis la table et
après on a des cours et le le pacte de à
des gars score et après bct bon et plein
de choses à faire les plans d'activité
en plus c'est fait dans un endroit où
bat aussi sympa le jardin de l'état
c'est moche toujours de m
j'ai eu l'occasion mois de d'assister à
un atelier aux tourelles et j'avais
trouvé que ça collait parfaitement avec
le thème l'enfant ya nature que nous
vous proposons cette année et il ya de
la manipulation il y à de la hoya le
côté pratique avec la nature et j'avais
trouvé ça génial et on a proposé ça pour
le bonheur des enfants
et là les enfants s'éclatent puisque
aussi apprécié cette manipulation de
papier et connaître aussi l'histoire de
du pape et de la provocation du parti